IS MACK'S SEARCH FOR AND
CRACKBERRY HIS SEARCH HISTORY,
NO SURPRISE, IT WILL STILL MAKE
YOU WANT TO BLEACH YOUR EYES,
ACCORDING TO THE DAILY MAIL, I
WONDER IF THEY DELIVERED.
HUNTER BIDEN SEARCH HISTORY ON
HIS INFAMOUS LAPTOP REVEALS AN
OBSESSION WITH HOMEMADE AND, BU
CREDIT TO HUNTER, HE KNOWS WHAT
HE LIKES STRAIGHT HE ALSO TYPED
IN HOT UKRAINIAN GAS COMPANIES
IN CHINESE OFFICIALS LOOKING FO
ROMANCE FOR THAT IS POLITICAL
COMMENTARY THERE.
THEY PUBLISHED HIS BROWSER
HISTORY WHICH WAS AT THE PEAK O
THE BIDEN MEETING SEASON.
HE REPORTEDLY VISITED 281
WEBSITE 91 OF THOSE BEING
PORNOGRAPHIC.
EXPERTS HAVE AUTHENTICATED THE
SEARCH HISTORY.
THE MAN KNEW HIS WAY AROUND HUB
A PLACE I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF.
WHAT COULD IT BE?
HUB?
HE WAS THE LONELY WIDOW WHICH
WAS NO SURPRISE AS HE WAS ALSO
DEEDING HIS DECEASED BROTHERS
WIDOW PARITY RECORDED AMATEUR
VIDEOS OF HIMSELF HAVING WITH
PROSTITUTES NEVERS SHOWING HIS
FACE AND THEN UPLOADING THEM
UNDER OUR EIGHT EAST, PRETTY
GROSS, BUT BETTER THAN WATCHING
BIDEN SCREW THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
AND IF THAT THAT'S NOT BAD
ENOUGH HE ALLEGEDLY TEXTED HIS
DAD A LINK TO A SITE BACK IN
2018 OR AT LEAST SOMEONE LABELE
DAD AND HIS PHONE, WE DON'T KNO
FOR SURE IT WAS JOE ALTHOUGH TH
VIDEO WAS CALLED HERE SNIFFERS
IN HEAT.
WE ASKED HIM FOR A COMMENT.
>> NO, NO, NO, LOOK.
I DIDN'T GET ANY MESSAGES.
I DIDN'T GET ANY LINKS.
NOBODY SENT ME ANY LINKS.
I DON'T EVEN LIKE THOSE LINKS,
DON'T LIKE CLICKING ON THOSE
LINKS.
WHY DO THEY CALL THEM LINKS
ANYWAY?
THEY'RE NOT REALLY LINKS ARE
THEY, THERE LIKE A SECOND DOOR
TO A ANOTHER WORLD.
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN THAT WORLD
.
I JUST WANT THINGS TO GO BACK T
THE OTHER WAY.
WHY IS IT SO QUIET?
>> TYRUS, DO YOU THINK IT'S ALL
THAT IT IS KIND OF LIBERATING
FOR EVERYONE TO KNOW YOUR
PREDILECTION?
BECAUSE NO ONE CAN AFFORD THIS
MUCH SHAME, BECAUSE IT'S TOO
COSTLY AT THIS LEVEL.
THERE IS SO MUCH STUFF, IT'S GO
TO GO ZERO, IT'S OUT THERE AND
DON'T CARE BECAUSE IT THERE IS
ACTUALLY FILM OF HIM BREAKING
WIND.
I ONCE WAS ASKED ABOUT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF SOMEONE WAS TO
BREAK INTO MY COMPUTER HISTORY.
I ONCE TALKED ABOUT THE TERM
BEAUTIFUL DEATH, THAT'S WHEN
SAMURAI HAS BEEN DISHONORED.
HE HAS SOME CEREMONIAL SWORDS,
AND HE TAKES THE SHARPEST ONE I
MY I TAKE THE SHARPEST ONE AND
HE THRUSTED INSIDE HIMSELF UNTI
HE BLEEDS TO DEATH.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
HUNTER APPARENTLY IS BRAVER THA
I AM AND AT THIS POINT, WHAT'S
LEFT?
WHEN YOU ARE SEARCHING FOR
LONELY WIDOWS AND CRACK MOMS?
I MEAN ROCK-BOTTOM, THE DEVIL I
LIKE ARE YOU ALL RIGHT DOWN
THERE?
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN THAT
.
JUST WOW.
>> NONE OF US COULD SURVIVE THI
KIND OF LIFESTYLE UNLESS WE WER
PART OF A POLITICAL FAMILY,
RIGHT?
IT WOULD BE LIKE IN LEISURE DAD
IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE, HE IS
STILL SELLING HALF THE
MILLION-DOLLAR PAINTINGS AFTER
THIS.
ARE YOU JEALOUS?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE, HE GETS A
WILD OUT.
I COULD NEVER GET AWAY WITH THI
STUFF.
I DON'T THINK LIKE ALL THE
SEARCHING AS A BIG DEAL, I THIN
IT'S ACTUALLY A PROBLEM HE
WASN'T MORE ADDICTED TO BECAUSE
HE'S WATCHING MORE, THEN HE
WOULDN'T HAVE TIME FOR ALL THEI
SHADY BUSINESS DEALINGS.
>> IT DOES EAT UP A LOT OF HIS
DAY.
>> NO, HE WASN'T ADDICTED, HE
WAS IN THAT.
HE WOULD'VE BEEN DECLINING THE
CALLS FROM THE CHINESE OFFICIAL
TO WATCH MORE FOREIGN.
>> YOU LOSE TRACK OF TIME WHEN
YOU GO DOWN THAT PATH.
>> IT LITERALLY.
>> HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT IT
WAS.
>> HE'S AN OVER ACHIEVER, HE WA
THE SMARTEST GUY COMING HE HAD
ALL THESE BUSINESS DEALINGS AND
WAS ABLE TO JUGGLE A ADDICTION
AT THE SAME TIME.
>> I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE GUY.
IT DOESN'T BOTHER ME.
LOOK, I'M 44 YEARS OLD, YOU LOO
THROUGH THE HORRORS OF THIS
WORLD, AND AFTER A WHILE YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO DESPERATELY FEEL
SOMETHING.
I GET IT, I JUST GET IT.
I WANT TO HANG OUT WITH HIM, YO
KNOW?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IN YOUR 40s, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A DINNER
PARTY AND GO TO DAVE AND BUSTER
AND HE'S LIKE ONE TO GO GREAVES
OF MILLS AND HIS A WHILE WHY
YOU'RE DOING CRACK?
YES, LET'S SEE WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT.
COULD GIVE THE SERVICE PICK ME
UP, HUNTER, IF YOU'RE WATCHING,
I AM INVITING YOU.
TO DRINK WITH ME AND THEN HANG
OUT WITH ME IN THE BATHROOM.
I AM OBLIGATED TO ASK YOU THIS,
KENNEDY BECAUSE IT IS THE
CLICHÉD QUESTION, BUT IMAGINE I
HUNTER WAS A MEMBER OF THE TRUM
FAMILY OR ANY REPUBLICAN FAMILY
I KNOW THAT SUCH AN EASY BIRD.
>> ARE YOU TRYING.
>> ME TO IMAGINE WHAT HE USES
THE PRIVATE BROWSER, HE'S NO
IDIOT 50 AND WONDER IF HE SEES
IT LIKE I DO.
I'M JUST TRYING TO IMAGINE WHAT
WIDOW IS LIKE, IS IT LIKE A
WOMAN DRESSED IN THE BLACK VEIL
AND THE GUY COMES OVER A.
I'VE GOT SOME KLEENEX FOR YOU.
HOLD ON, IT'S IN MY PANTS.
HERE YOU GO.
LIKE WHAT IS WIDOW?
WHAT IS THE SETUP LIKE, AND WE
ARE COMING OUT OF A PANDEMIC
WHERE EVERYBODY CAN COVER
THEMSELVES, CAN YOU IMAGINE
SHAKING HANDS WITH HIM VERY JUS
THE PICTURE OF THAT, I CAN'T
IMAGINE.
LIKE MONKEYPOX WOULD BE A RELIE
FROM HIM.
>> HE GAVE HUNTER POX BOX TWO
MONKEYS.
>> THE MONKEY WAS LIKE NO THANK
YOU.
IS LIKE I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU
SLEPT WITH HUNTER.
>> IT'S LIKE RICK JAMES, COCAINE
, A HELL OF A DRUG.
>> I GUESS HIS WAS LIKE METH,
RIGHT?
>> I THINK IT IS CRACKBERRY.
>> BUT SAY NO TO DRUGS.
I LIKE ENDING EVERY SEGMENT LIK
THAT.
>> YOU A